madame monsieur bonsoir voici les petits
trucs et nous allons développer dans ce
journal dans le conflit en yougoslavie
le président russe hausse le ton et
évoque les risques d'une guerre
européenne voire mondiale si les états
unis poussent en même temps la russie
assure qu'elle ne s'impliquera pas
militairement dans la crise l'aide
humanitaire en albanie en macédoine avec
aujourd'hui sur la sellette le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés
son efficacité est mise en cause par
différentes organisations l'heure qu'en
france la solidarité s'organise des
colis pour les réfugiés et des milliers
d'appels pour les accueillir
un rapport accablant qui met en cause la
gestion du président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de la
corse-du-sud gilbert casanova
irrégularités et traduit sanctuaire les
dix ans de la pyramide du louvre près de
6 millions de visiteurs pour la seule
année 98 un monument de la culture
française de 200 tonnes d'acier et de
verre
je vous proposerai ce journal avec à
moscou la mise en garde de boris eltsine
aux occidentaux
boris eltsine qui évoque que les risques
d'une application directe de la russie
dans le conflit yougoslave
cette déclaration fait suite à celle
aussitôt démenti du président de la
douma qui déclarait ce matin que des
missiles russes étaient braqués sur les
états de l'otan reconstitution de cette
journée avec notre correspondant gilles
rabin premier épisode le kremlin ce
matin l'ouverture des bureaux
boris elstine reçoit le président de la
douma guennadi seleznov qui vient rendre
compte de son voyage à belgrade sélénium
ils n'arriveront pas à casser desservent
l'île physiquement ni moralement aucun
moyen sauf à lévis qu'ils aient tous
yacine
j'ai déjà dit à l'otan aux américains et
aux allemands de nous pousser pas aux
actes militaires sinon il y aurait une
guerre européenne c'est sûr et peut-être
une guerre mondiale je la suite sera en
caméra ses désirs 30 embrouiller le
souvenir qu'il a donné l'ordre de
pointer les missiles nucléaires sur les
pays de l'otan deuxième épisode est elle
si elle reçoit deux responsables
régionaux
ils veulent passer à l'opération
terrestre
il s'y prépare
ils veulent tout simplement envahir la
yougoslavie en faire leur protectorat
nous ne pouvons pas l'admettre dit
eltsine qui ajoute aussitôt qu'il refuse
toujours toute aide militaire au serbe
troisième épisode c'est les affrontera
zuma question est il vrai que le
président vous oublie ce matin que les
missiles étaient pointés sur les pays de
l'otan oui il a dit que sur les pays qui
menaient des actions militaires contre
la yougoslavie de la douma pas un mot
sur lui si le démenti officiel tombe
écrit d'abord au complot attire
expliquant la malcombe histoire d'une
bourde ou histoire d'un piège jeudi
prochain à nice atypique communiste va
s'ouvrir le débat sur une procédure de
destitution de boris eltsine
aurait on voulu discréditer le président
de la douma et avec lui le parti
communiste en cette veille de pâques
orthodoxe un homme un seul à tenter de
calmer le jeu alexei ii le patriarche
avec un double appel à une trêve les
frappes et à milosevic à brescia j'en
appelle aux dirigeants de la yougoslavie
seule la paix la dignité pour tous y
compris les albanais et niche du kosovo
sauvegarderont la sécurité du pays
c'est établirons l'ordre et la concorde
ils s'angoissent le patriarche conclu
sur une semonce aux hommes politiques de
russie cette fois qui la peine
le réseau et en direct de moscou gilles
rabin la déclaration de boris eltsine
ressemble à un avertissement à
destination de l'occident une façon
peut-être de dire clairement que la
russie ne veut pas rester en jeu wii
béatrice c'est même un triple
avertissement de boris eltsine d'abord
une ligne rouge que les occidentaux ne
doivent pas franchir cette ligne rouge
c'est celle d'une invasion terrestre du
kosovo par les troupes de l'otan
ensuite une mise en garde avant les
frappes on n'a pas tenu compte des
avertissements de la russie on l'a
humilié l'occident ne va pas infliger
une deuxième humiliation à la russie une
humiliation de trop
enfin l'occident doit tenir compte tirer
les leçons de cette folle journée à
moscou et tenir compte des extrêmes
tensions de la vie politique intérieure
russes il y a dans ce pays beaucoup de
gens prêts à jouer avec le feu
l'irresponsabilité des députés est
légendaire au point que depuis longtemps
les russes de la rue ont baptisé la
douma douze hommes c'est-à-dire la
maison des fous merci gilles et puis en
fin d'après midi on a appris que
madeleine albright le secrétaire d'état
américain rencontrera oslo son homologue
russe igor ivanov en albanie c'est
mercredi prochain qu'un contingent de
8000 hommes sera déployé une force d'
aide humanitaire avec dans ce pays
l'installation d'un quartier général de
l'otan
en attendant sur place la situation
sanitaire et logistique des camps de
réfugiés s'améliore petit à petit la
présence de médecins d'infirmiers qui
assure les premiers secours anne
pensionnés philippe jasmin pour ce
groupe là ce sera là tant 123 et
attendant 1,41 ses larmes et albanaise
qui répartit les familles mais c'est la
croix rouge italienne qui a installé le
camp un gros travail effectué en un
temps record
pour cette famille le voyage a été long
jusqu ici voilà un nom qui l'ont quitté
leur mise
depuis il erre de village en village
réfugiés dans leur propre pays et
maintenant en albanie on est très bien
ici là on n'a pas à se plaindre
en comparaison avec les autres jours
évidemment c'est mieux mais si c'est
possible on voudrait vraiment rentrer
chez nous une enfilade de tentes kaki
survolée par des hélicoptères c'est ce
qu'ils ont connu de mieux depuis un
moment
ici au moins il y à l'eau est une vraie
présence médicale mais déjà on commence
à refuser du monde
dukan est de 5000 personnes mais
actuellement nous n'avons alors on va
essayer de se réorganiser pour l
utiliser des postes disponibles armée
albanaise fabrique du pain sous une
descente avec des fourneaux de campagne
une centaine parole
les soldats boulanger espère ainsi
répondre aux besoins du camp
l'installation du camp italien comme on
l'appelle ici n'a pas permis de résorber
tous les campements de fortune encore
installés en ville
selon le hcr il ya encore 80 mille
réfugiés à couquèques certains d'entre
eux vont prendre la route mais il faudra
sans doute construire d'autres camps
pour ceux qui vont rester et cette
journée de vendredi aura été marquée sur
le terrain par des échanges de tirs le
long de la frontière entre le nord de
l'albanie et la yougoslavie
il s'agirait de combats entre les forces
de l'ue ces cas et des gardes frontières
ces affrontements sporadiques se situe
dans une région reculée difficile d'en
évaluer l'importance sera respecte
l'albanie a toujours été la base arrière
de loups checa nous sommes dans le nord
de l'albanie ces images ont été tournées
en cachette l'armée de libération du
kosovo refusent que l'on filmé ce camp
où se trouve un millier d'hommes en deux
ans lucho qui a réussi à devenir une
véritable organisation
politico-militaire attirant beaucoup de
jeunes albanais radicaliser mais depuis
le début de la guerre le tchèque a perdu
ses bases du nord du kosovo
thomas legrand a pu rejoindre les
combattants près de pêche est vraiment
faible militairement avec son armement
léger incident elle dispose d'un réseau
de renseignement et d'observation est
cité
qui couvre près de 40% du territoire du
kosovo et il semble que l'otan utilise
largement les informations fournies par
le tchèque a plusieurs objectifs
désignés à son chef de région par le
capitaine de la brigade 136 rogova ont
été rapidement transmise aux yeux le
lendemain ces sites était bombardé par
l'otan l'otan qui disent donc loup checa
comme moyen d'information mais pour
autant les etats-unis se demandent s'ils
peuvent avoir confiance en lui checa
s'il faut tard mais le tchèque a comme
ils ont armé les croates il ya quatre
ans carlou tchèque a été fondé par des
anciens militants maoïstes ayant une
conception fort peu démocratiques de la
société
son leader hashim thaçi se déclare
premier ministre du gouvernement
provisoire kosovar ironie de l'histoire
il est devenu un interlocuteur
privilégié du secrétaire d'état
américaine madeleine albright aux états
unis bill clinton mardi une nouvelle
fois la détermination de l'otan à
l'égard de slobodan milosevic le
président serbe qui manipule la
situation et donne une illusion de
conformité partiel avec les exigences de
la science a ajouté le bureau américain
l'occident ne se laissera pas duper
n'accepterons pas de demi mesure alors
que nous entrons dans la troisième
semaine des opérations militaires de
l'otan de nouveaux bombardements hier
soir à belgrade
d'autres à pristina au kosovo le temps
qui reconnaît avoir fait sans doute des
victimes civiles parlant de dégâts
collatéraux tout à l'heure à belgrade
la population a été appelée à protéger
le siège de la télévision française
corner les catapultes h sont poursuivis
durant toute la journée toute la nuit
dernière sur le pont d'envol du ter de
roosevelt en mer adriatique venus
renforcer le dispositif aérien de l'otan
avec les 15 élèves 16 de l'us air force
base et abyane au les chasseurs
bombardiers de ce porte avions
américains ont touché plusieurs cibles
effectivement en serbie ou au kosovo
les missiles se sont abattus notamment
sur ce dépôt de carburant à smederevo
située à une cinquantaine de kilomètres
au sud est de belgrade
l'objectif est toujours le même couper
les approvisionnements en carburant de
l'armée yougoslave un autre bombardement
entièrement détruit cette usine
automobile à kragujevac à 120 km au sud
de la capitale
cette usine fabriquait des voitures vava
marque légendaire
yougoslavie elle était d'ailleurs la
seule usine de pays à produire des
automobiles mais aussi d'après l'otan la
principale usine d'armement yougoslave
et c'est pour cette raison qu'elle a été
visé d'après belgrade
ce raid aurait fait une centaine de
blessés hier soir avant même la verte
aérienne à belgrade
les habitants de la capitale se sont
rassemblés sur les ponts pour former une
chaîne humaine
même scène à novi sad au nord du pays
cette fois sur un pont routier ici tous
les ponts enjambant le danube ont déjà
été détruits par les frappes aériennes
les autorités de belgrade ont demandé à
la population de servir de bouclier
humain jusqu'à la fin des bombardements
pour empêcher le temps d'atteindre ses
cibles
ces images comme celles de la
préparation de la pâque orthodoxe en
pleine rue fortement relayée par la
télévision serbe déplaise aux
commandants des forces de l'alliance qui
aimeraient détruire tous les relais de
télévision pour mettre fin à ce qu'il
qualifie de propagande
il faut dire que dans ce domaine la télé
de belgrade fait fort en diffusant
notamment ses clips anti otan que vous
allez voir
pendant ce temps au palais présidentiel
à belgrade slobodan milosevic recevaient
une importante délégation de militaires
russes parmi eux des chefs traditionnels
kozak ainsi que des généraux venus dire
à leurs frères slave leur solidarité une
simple visite semble-t-il pour l'instant
de courtoisie aujourd'hui la télévision
serbe nous montre également largement
ses chars qui attendent de pied ferme au
kosovo je cite l'agresseur mais rien sur
la colonne blindée que l'otan disent
avoir détruit en fin de journée en
adriatique les chasseurs bombardiers du
theodore roosevelt se préparait à une
nouvelle vague de frappes sur la
yougoslavie
arrivé hier à belgrade le président du
parlement chypriote devait tenter une
médiation pour obtenir la libération des
trois militaires prisonniers américains
la rencontre avec slobodan milosevic a
bien eu lieu cet après midi
mais selon un communiqué officiel pas de
mention du cadre de ces trois soldats ce
modèle ne milosevic qui a déclaré la
yougoslavie défend aujourd'hui l'europe
le droit et la justice face à
l'hégémonie américaine en italie sur la
base d'istres anna renforcement du
dispositif français avec l'envoi de
quatre nouveaux mirage 2000 qui devrait
arriver dans les jours qui viennent
les forces aériennes françaises
comprennent différentes composantes dont
les fameux mirage 2000c les fameux
chasseur qui assurent la sécurité de
l'espace aérien à l'aise devant le
ballet des mirage 2000 c c'est comme
couverture aérienne
ce sont eux qui assure seul ou en
coopération avec d'autres appareils de
l'otan
la sécurité de l'espace aérien où
opèrent les avions d'attac
ce sont des chasseurs tic leur rôle est
d'intercepter d'éventuelles intrusions
2000 serbes
ils étaient quatre ce matin avoir pris
l'air à l'aube pour un vol de six heures
avec 6 ravitaillement en vol une mission
épuisante
car la surveillance de l'espace aérien
demande une attention constante et une
capacité de réaction immédiate alors les
pilotes city
un peu fatigué ce matin tout s'est bien
passé les quatre mirages sont rentrés
avec tous leurs missiles air air qui ont
aussitôt été désarmé depuis le début du
conflit la chasse serbe s'est du reste
montré très discrète depuis le début des
opérations nous n'avons pas été amenés à
attirer domicile mais il faut je vous le
rappelle il faut être conscient de notre
mission est aussi et avant tout une
mission de dissuasion ne serait ce que
par notre simple présence en vol
on n'a jamais le droit de de
sous-estimer
de sous-estimer un adversaire et on doit
toujours se dire qu'il est prêt soit
fait quelque chose soit réagir et on
sait jamais quand est on ne sait jamais
sous quelle forme
à peine arrivé à leurs parkings les
appareils sont aussitôt révisé remis en
condition prêt à être réutilisé avec
d'autres pilotes au premier ordre de
l'état major allié qui ne lésinent pas
les utiliser ces mirage 2000 c honte à
eux seuls effectué une centaine de
missions en 16 jours le plus beau
démenti aux rumeurs venues d'angleterre
selon lesquelles on se méfierait des
français est en effet vive réaction de
la france après les affirmations d'un
journal anglais le daily telegraph qui a
indiqué que la france était
volontairement tenu à l'écart de
certaines décisions de l'otan concernant
les opérations militaires au kosovo
laurent bouvier une tempête dans un
verre d'eau diplomatique à la lecture ce
matin du daily telegraph et sous la
plume du correspondant à washington de
ce journal londonien le spectre d'une
faille entre alliés et brièvement
réapparu
selon ce journal les américains ferait
des cachotteries aux français par peur
que ces derniers ne livrent aux
autorités yougoslave des informations
sur les frappes de lodja vieille
méfiance anglo saxon envers des français
toujours soupçonné d'amitié avec les
serbes et moi dans les états majors
aient démenti immédiat et gêné des
autorités britanniques
je n'ai aucune preuve concernant ces
allégations et je ne crois absolument
pas que la france puisse faire cela
j'ai une totale confiance dans les
français et plus particulièrement dans
mon ami hubert védrine nous partageons
totalement lui même objectif et je peux
vous assurer que ces objectifs sont
aussi ceux de la france démenties
également des américains de l'otan et
des français par la voix du ministre de
la défense alain richard
cela dit il faut savoir qu'à l'otan il
existe plusieurs cercles de décision
avec évidemment différents degrés
d'accès aux informations par exemple à
aviano en italie c'est le chaos qu le
centre de contrôle des opérations
aériennes
dirigée par un général américain qui
tous les jours donne les ordres de volée
de frappes aux avions de l'alliance ses
ordres sont contenues dans un document
top secret la théoleyre targeting gordon
mais en fait il existe deux documents
différents l'un diffusé à l'ensemble des
pays concernés par les frappes
l'autre réserve est exclu
yvan aux américains ce deuxième document
concerne les vols et les objectifs des f
117 des b-52 des b1 et b2 tous les
avions furtifs et stratégiques
américains les etats-unis veulent
protéger un certain nombre
d'informations sur ces avions même
vis-à-vis de leurs alliés de tous leurs
alliés france grande bretagne et
allemagne inclus mais en direct des
bosselles jean-marc il use
à l'évidence les allégations du daily
telegraph compte tenu du nombre de
démanteler le temps n'ont pas été prises
au sérieux
vous savez béatrice dire que la france
n'est pas dans le coup qu'elle est mise
à l'écart ce n'est pas c'est un petit
peu absurde parce que si vous voulez
pour des opérations aériennes il faut
coordonner les missions des pilotes des
missions de bombardement mais aussi de
protection de surveillance des
couvertures et il serait suicidaire pour
tous que cette coordination soit partiel
deuxièmement c'est vrai la france a une
position un peu particulière puisqu'elle
n'appartient pas aux structures
intégrées de l'alliance
mais depuis deux ou trois ans elle
appartient au comité militaire ce qui
veut dire qu'elle a en permanence une
centaine d'officiers dans les rouages
opérationnel et d état major de l'otan
alors il n'y a pas d'os dans le boudin
je cite me disais tout à l'heure un haut
responsable militaire
alors deuxième joue aussi quand on parle
d'un axe paris belgrade s'est également
absurde il faudrait supposer que pour
d'obscures raisons politiques la france
informerait ses adversaires et leur
permettrait de descendre des pilotes
français totalement absurde
reste qu'il serait instructif de savoir
quelles étaient les intentions de la
mystérieuse source anonyme qui a informé
le journaliste du très conservateur
daily telegraph
merci jean marc et loose le secrétaire
général de l'onu à genève appelle à un
cessez-le-feu immédiat au kosovo
entraînant une fois accepté la
suspension des bombardements
kofi annan demande à belgrade de retirer
chez force de mettre fin à la campagne
d'intimidation et d'expulsion de la
population et puis dans l'après midi le
secrétaire général de l'otan a approuvé
cette déclaration
ces derniers jours nous envoyés spéciaux
vous en montrer dans leurs reportages
le déploiement de l'aide humanitaire en
albanie mais aussi en macédoine où l'on
compte maintenant plus de cent mille
réfugiés et c'est là en macédoine
l'efficacité du haut commissariat aux
réfugiés a été contestée aujourd'hui par
différentes organisations humanitaires
qui accuse cet organisme des nations
unies de bafouer les devoirs minimum
d'assistance
valérie fournis ou frédéric basket
madame ogata haut commissaire aux
réfugiés a commencé sa visite en
macédoine par le camp de brazza un camp
géré par les troupes de l'alliance qui
compte aujourd'hui plus de 26 mille
réfugiés et la visite est conduite par
un militaire car le hr n'est pas présent
dans ce camp puis madame ogata
rencontrer les autorités macédoniennes
pour en savoir plus sur le sort des
réfugiés disparu lors de l'évacuation
musclée du camp de blatche et par les
macédoniens maintenant nous avons eu des
chats
l'idef pleut précède le sait qu'il lui
faut recouper les informations
elle apprendra plus tard qu'il sont 1200
disparu évacué vers la turquie et la
grèce
mais lors de sa visite elle a surtout
obtenu un accord sur les frontières
j'ai insisté pour un accord sur les
frontières et j'ai obtenu qu'elle reste
ouverte
le président macédonien et moi avons
tiré les leçons de ces derniers jours
des frontières ou depuis le début de
l'exode le hr n'est pas présent comme
ici à irin c'est pourtant c'est sa
mission d'assurer la sécurité des
réfugiés et les seules troupes présentes
sont macédonienne aux frontières comme
dans les camps que à propos de la
sécurité loi chère ne va pas évidemment
assurer la sécurité des camps ça c'est
le problème du gouvernement cette
absence du hr dans les camps et aux
frontières pour enregistrer les réfugiés
a provoqué aujourd'hui la colère de
médecins sans frontières
ce que nous demandons c'est que le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés comme ces
semaines boulot comme si tu es le faire
fasse son boulot c'est-à-dire appliquer
le mandat international qui consiste à
assurer protection et assistance aux
réfugiés
il faut séparer le militaire de
l'humanitaire et nous on est là pour
faire ça pour organiser les assistances
il faut qu'il nous laisse faire ça c'est
pas chose à le faire ça les soldats
c'est la guerre quant au gouvernement
macédonien
ils surveillent toujours de près les
camps six troupes y assurent une
présence constante et nous rejoignent en
direct dans un de ces camps de réfugiés
en macédoine jérôme baugnies quelle est
la situation aujourd'hui sur place qu
avez-vous pu constater ce soir béatrice
j'ai un peu de mal à vous entendre oeil
oui je vous entends bien triste je vous
distingue disons ya un peu de bruit dans
le camp il ya des appels vous savez pour
que les familles se retrouvent
il ya des appels qui sont organisées ici
maintenant les gens sont un peu rassurés
ils voient un peu mieux physiquement et
moralement
mais il ya une grande incertitude sur
leur avenir et tous ceux qui sont dans
ce camp autour de moi ils sont vingt
mille sème le disait valéry fournioux je
suis en quelque sorte prisonnier de ce
camp ils ne peuvent en sortir qu à
condition de partir vers des pays
étrangers le gouvernement macédonien ne
veux pas que ces réfugiés restent en
macédoine chez l'habitant
donc la seule solution pour sortir du
camp c'est d'accepter d'aller dans les
pays d'accueil provisoires comme la
turquie la norvège où l'allemagne là
quelques centaines qui sont partis hier
quelques centaines encore aujourd'hui
mais la plupart et 20000 reste ici en
espérant pouvoir éventuellement rentrer
chez eux leur problème bien sûr c'est
d'avoir des nouvelles de leurs familles
et les journalistes sont littéralement
assaillis par tous ces réfugiés et qui
leur demandent d'utiliser quelques
secondes leurs téléphones portables pour
appeler en macédoine ou pour appeler en
suisse en allemagne ou même en france où
il ya déjà des membres de leur famille
et qui pourraient les aider à sortir
d'ici revenons jérôme si vous m'entendez
sur l'incident hier à la frontière entre
la macédoine et la yougoslavie incident
militaire
un accrochage au cours duquel un homme a
été tué
oui absolument béatrice c'était tout
près d'ici à une quinzaine de kilomètres
dans le village duo blatche et dans les
montagnes une patrouille de routine de
l'armée macédonienne a été prise sous le
feu des hommes en civil armés un ou
plusieurs hommes est l'un des hommes de
cette patrouille a été blessé
mortellement
c'est un incident de frontière qui
pourraient être graves en tout cas qui a
été assez rare ces dernières années
jusqu'au mois de janvier dernier
des patrouilles de l'onu surveiller
cette frontière qui n'est pas très
précises entre la yougoslavie et la
toute nouvelle macédoine mais maintenant
ces patrouilles ne sont plus là il n'y a
plus de casques bleus et ces incidents
sont sans doute symptomatique de l'état
d'ébullition dans lequel les frappes de
l'otan ont mis cette région des balkans
merci jérôme venue de votre témoignage
en yougoslavie marie france garaud et
l'ancien député alain griotteray et est
aujourd'hui à belgrade
il dénonce l'attitude de la france vous
propose d'écouter marie france garaud à
notre gouvernement nous avons commis une
faute une faute contre le droit il faut
contre la liberté contre la fidélité de
l'alliance quelle faute contre l'amitié
au cul si l'état français parlent d'une
seule voix dans ce conflit du kosovo
lionel jospin et jacques chirac étant
sur la même ligne lionel jospin qui
était l'invité de france 2 hier et qui a
redit la position de la france
en revanche dans les rangs du parti
communiste des opinions très divergentes
tranchait parfois contradictoires il ya
ceux qui s'opposent ouvertement frappes
de l'otan et d'autres qui les tolère
c'est ce même sentiment qu'on retrouvait
chez les militants de base à bordeaux
allemand nicosie et frédéric d'un chèque
comme chaque jeudi soir ils manifestent
ils sont environ 200 ici à bordeaux
ils disent que la france doit se
démarquer de l'opération militaire de
l'otan il ya là des trotskistes des
proches du mouvement des citoyens
mais la majorité ce sont des communistes
parce qu'à la différence des autres
militants politiques les communistes
sont majoritairement opposés à
l'intervention actuelle pour céline par
exemple les images quotidiennes de
destructions dues au bombardement ne
font que renforcer ce sentiment même si
c'était prévu je construis des
bombardements ont fait qu'accélérer les
choses est toujours historiquement très
critique envers toute intervention
militaire française à l'étranger les
communistes sont plus divisés sur la
politique susceptible de faire reculer
milosevic
les militants bordelaise se
reconnaissent toutefois dans la ligne
incarné par robert hue la mutation du
parti communiste a pour double vocation
de développer l'esprit critique et de
renvoyer les prises de décision aux
adhérents et aux citoyens eux-mêmes
mobiliser les pacifistes les opposants
conflit tel est l'objet de ce bureau
départemental ou leurs proches effet au
pouvoir et notamment de premier ministre
de ne pas assez écouté le parti notre
avis à un déni de démocratie a ajouté à
l'opération d'une hot and qui n'a pas
consulté le nu qui est intervenu sous
l'entière mainmise américaine c'est
assez inquiétant pour la démocratie en
europe
ces manifestations dans différentes
régions ne sont pas imposante mais elle
reflète bien les inquiétudes réelles
d'une partie de la gauche plurielle
prête à se faire davantage entendre si
le conflit se prolongeait en france les
27 premiers réfugiés kosovars sont
arrivés aujourd'hui en seine-saint-denis
provisoirement hébergés d'abord à epinay
puis en fin de journée ces hommes ces
femmes et ces enfants étaient accueillis
non loin de là à vaujours jean trudelle
annick pascal caron des enfants qui
retrouvent le sourire la vie plus forte
que les souffrances de l'exil
les 27 premiers réfugiés du kosovo sont
arrivés ce matin à epinay sur seine
les adultes eux dont les traits tirés et
les visages fermés
ils ne peuvent pas encore oublié après
quinze jours d'errance il n'aspire plus
court repos et ne veulent plus parler à
chaque fois effectivement qu'on une
interview en fin de compte on replonge
dans l'institut dans ce qu'ils ont vécu
effectivement à l'heure actuelle ils
arrivent à saturation
par peur des représailles pour leur
famille restée sur place et sans doute
aussi pour ne pas compromettre ceux qui
les ont aidés à passer de frontières en
frontière
ils ne diront rien sur leur errance
quand ils ont quitté poggia au kosovo
pour l'albanie puis l'italie puis la
frontière française dans les alpes à
montgenèvre encore un car cet après midi
entre epinay-sur-seine et vaujours en
seine-saint-denis
mais cette fois ci un convoi de la croix
rouge française sous escorte officielle
et surtout dans la poche de chacun des
vingt-sept réfugiés des autorisations de
séjour en bonne et due forme
maintenant effectivement ils ont des
papiers pour l'instant pour une période
de trois mois en france
ils vont pouvoir souffler un petit peu
resserre le frein en reprendre contact
avec leurs familles est donc patent
c'est au niveau diplomatique
on va essayer de pouvoir leur donner une
permission pour sortir du territoire
français pour rejoindre leur famille en
angleterre ou en belgique
ce soir c'est donc dans ce centre
d'hébergement de vos jours ils vont
pouvoir reprendre des forces et oublier
leurs cauchemars et pour la première
fois peut-être envisager l'avenir avec
un sourire retrouvé pour tous
la solidarité au rendez-vous la mise en
place d'un numéro vert d'appel recensant
les offres d'accueil de réfugiés en
france répond à un afflux massif de
propositions même mobilisation soutenue
sur le terrain à travers les
associations elles à margaux jean
bernard schmidt
à quelque chose au bon jour aujourd'hui
ils étaient 20 à répondre au téléphone
et ils seront 50 dès lundi le ministère
de la santé a en effet décidé de
renforcer la cellule d'accueil kosovo
dans les appels sont nombreux plus de
110000 pour la seule soirée d'hier est
au bout du fil la même solidarité dit
prêt à aider beaucoup n'ont pas de
facilités financières mais sont prêts à
héberger légion la durée possible de
l'hébergement à chaque appel les mêmes
questions reviennent
il faut évaluer la place disponible le
profil de ceux qui sont prêts à
accueillir des réfugiés et leur
expliquer la marche à suivre
ensuite l'ensemble de ces informations
sont transmises par le biais du
ministère à l'ensemble des directions
départementales des affaires sanitaires
et sociales et celle ci dans une un
délai d'une dizaine de jours va
recontacter en fait les personnes qui
ont offert leur leur hébergement
sur le terrain les associations aussi se
mobilise la croix rouge a déjà commencé
à recenser les lieux d'hébergement
qu'elle peut offrir aux réfugiés
recensés ça veut dire évaluer un petit
peu les surfaces que l'on peut mettre à
disposition voir dans quel état sont les
lieux et voir aussi combien de personnes
on peut loger dans tel ou tel lieu
220 places c'est simple et c'est ici à
france terre d'asile que sont ensuite
centralisée l'ensemble des offres
d'accueil venant des associations depuis
quelques jours les propositions affluent
de toute la france au total 3000
kosovars pourrait d'ores et déjà être
accueillis mais ce dispositif pourrait
s'avérer insuffisant tout dépend de la
politique gouvernementale
tout dépend du nombre de gens que nous
allons accueillir au delà de ces 3000
personnes il faudra sans doute imaginer
un autre dispositif
ce soir le haut commissariat pour les
réfugiés a réuni en urgence et
représentants des ministères et des
associations concernées pour coordonner
l'accueil des kosovars au delà de
l'hébergement
ils devront surtout décider des
procédures qui permettront aux réfugiés
d'entrer sur le territoire français
depuis ce matin la croix rouge et la
poste ont uni leurs efforts pour
acheminer les premiers colis à
destination des réfugiés
une opération qui devrait se poursuivre
jusqu'au 18 avril les militants sans
yann genty classe et un collègue comme
tous ses collègues de la poste dry time
in vite ch se mobilisent aujourd'hui
elle peut être un peu plus que les
autres en raison de ses origines
kosovars son rôle distribué gratuitement
ses cartons pour emballer vivres des
vêtements destinés aux réfugiés du
kosovo
c'est très important fall envoyé les
colis étoiles aider les gens une
souffrance un drame qui ne peut laisser
ni indifférents ni insensible au minimum
face et c'est tellement un film chaud au
coeur c'est tout à fait normal c'est le
moins qu'on puisse faire et une
solidarité qui va s'opérer dans toute la
france dans les dix sept mille bureaux
de la poste la poste poursuit sa mission
d'universalité je dirais en gros
j'aurais tendance à dire que tout ce qui
est humain est nôtre à la poste
tous les colis collectés atterriront
dans un entrepôt comme celui ci les
volontaires devront alors recomposer des
cartons dans chacun d'eux féculents
conserves fruits secs et savon de
marseille
pour l'instant les dons proviennent des
supermarchés avec l'opération poste la
croix rouge craint d'être débordés
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
de personne pour nous aider encore à
faire les cartons puisque nous avons à
l'heure actuelle stocker 10 tonnes
depuis depuis samedi et nous avons eu
les quarts conclus depuis ce matin ces
colis seront parmi les premiers à être
acheminés dans les pays voisins du
kosovo par une organisation humanitaire
française depuis l'organisation action
contre la faim enverra vers la macédoine
2 500 tonnes de farine de blé
huit camions devaient prendre le départ
aujourd'hui en tout 25 poids lourds pour
acheminer ses vivres à destination des
réfugiés du kosovo
voilà donc ce que l'on pouvait dire
aujourd'hui sur le conflit en libye slah
vie à l'étranger cette information un
coup d'état au niger le président aurait
été assassiné à l'aéroport de niamey
ibrahim baré maïnassara arrivé au
pouvoir en 96 aurait été tué par des
mutins printemps ce soir de source
diplomatique on évoque l'hypothèse
l'hypothèse d'une tentative de fuite du
président mais rien n'est confirmé
et puis cette dépêche nous indique que
des militaires fortement armés
contrôlent depuis la fin d'après midi la
ville de niamey au chapitre politique en
france l'annoncé cet après midi d'une
liste commune aux européennes
charles pasqua et philippe de villiers
unissent leur route et font donc liste
commune ensemble ils partagent les mêmes
restrictions à l'égard de l'europe et
leur opposition à la guerre des forces
de l'otan charles pasqua sera tête de
liste est la seyne-sur-mer près de toul
où un attentat hier soir un bureau de
poste en a été la cible les dégâts
matériels n'est pas de blesser d'autres
attentats avaient déjà visé des
bâtiments administratifs attentat alors
revendiqué par le flnc canal historique
l'inspection générale des finances vient
de rendre un rapport accablant sur la
gestion de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de la corse-du-sud en
question de nombreuses irrégularités
mais aussi le train de vie pharaonique
de son président gilbert casanova l'une
des figures de lille parce qu'elle dit
c'est bon pour le scandale qu'on ait pu
avoir décidé d'envoyer une commission
denquête en corse
c'était l'an dernier gilbert casanova
s'élevaient déjà contre la création
d'une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
l'homme n'apprécie guère qu'on soupçonne
la corse
ces notables notable parmi lesquels il
occupe une place de choix leaders
nationalistes modérés
il est aussi le tout puissant président
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
de corse-du-sud épinglé aujourd'hui par
l'inspection générale des finances igf
s'intéresse tout d'abord au train de vie
du président exemple près de 7000 francs
pour une nuit d'hôtel pour deux à paris
gilbert casanova dit avoir remboursé
cette somme par la suite aux traditions
salée douze mille francs pour un repas
pour quatre dans un restaurant de luxe
avec d'importants investisseurs
américains raconte gilbert casanova qui
trouve ses frais de représentation
parfaitement justifiée qu'est ce que
vous appelez les frais de représentation
énorme
c'est à dire 12 mille francs en invitant
des hauts responsables de la croisière
c'était frais de réseau de
représentations énorme de faire qu'à
dormir quelqu'un pour 6000 francs dans
l'hôtel meurice ces deux retraits de
représentation énorme c'est quand je me
déplace d'aller dormir au méridien à
paris ce sont des frais de
représentation énorme
donc il faut me dire dans le statut des
chambres monsieur casanova président de
la chambre de commerce on vous réduit
votre budget on vous donne une un
montant forfaitaire de 500 à 600 francs
essayez de vous débrouiller avec ça mais
moi on m'a jamais dit qu'il en était
ainsi l'ijf critique aussi la politique
de recrutement de la chambre de commerce
et sa façon de passer les marchés 62
dossier entaché d'irrégularités sur les
85 examiné par les inspecteurs
le rapport devrait être transmis bientôt
à la justice au parquet de décider alors
d'éventuelles poursuites
la ville de saint dizier en haute marne
ville morte depuis ce matin pour
protester contre le risque de
suppression de quelques 500 emplois les
barrages aux entrées de la ville pour
empêcher la circulation les manifestants
ont distribué des tracts et allumé et
quelques feux une opération pour sauver
l'emploi métallurgique
les barrages ont été levés en fin
d'après midi alors qu'une délégation de
grévistes se rendait à la préfecture
après l'annoncé surprise de la banque
centrale européenne qui a baissé son
taux directeur un signal fort
perçu comme une confiance dans la
stabilité des prix et de la croissance
voici les répercussions pratique que
pourrait avoir cette mesure
qu'ils aient réduit les taux d'intérêt
championne chapelle thierry breton
sachant que la banque centrale
européenne a diminué d'un demi point son
taux directeur
quels seront les effets concrets pour
les particuliers et donc combien de
temps réponse un crédit immobilier moins
cher immédiatement ou presque ceux qui
ont déjà contracté un emprunt peuvent le
renégocier
il y a quelques années les taux étaient
plus élevés même beaucoup plus élevés
donc ils peuvent renégocier à des taux
plus bas et puis ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
je crois que c'est l'occasion parce que
les taux d'intérêt sont particulièrement
bas historiquement très bas ils vont le
rester un certain temps mais on ne peut
pas dire qu'on aime tant et je crois
qu'il faut en profiter maintenant
l'argent est moins cher pour en profiter
il faut donc négocier avec son banquier
déjà en un an les taux pour l'immobilier
ont chuté en moyenne de 6 à 5 pour cent
en revanche peu d'espoir de baisse pour
les crédits à la consommation dans un
crédit à consommation la part du coût de
l'argent ne représente qu'un tiers
donc c'est 0 50 centimes sont déjà
diluée mais le signal envoyé hier par la
banque centrale peut avoir surtout un
effet psychologique
c'est son premier geste depuis la
naissance de l'euro et c'est un geste
très optimiste nous disons en quelque
sorte à nos concitoyens nous avons
confiance que les prix seront stables
c'est ce qui nous permet de baisser les
taux d'intérêt et en baissant les taux
d'intérêt nous donnons un peu plus
d'élan à l'économie pour que cet élan se
transforme en croissance et en emplois
la banque centrale adresse tout de même
un conseil aux gouvernements faire plus
d'efforts pour réduire les déficits dans
l'actualité cette affaire d' esclavage
celle d'une jeune mineure de 16 ans qui
était séquestrée par un couple habitant
les yvelines l'homme et la femme ont été
écroués olivier sainte marie et frédéric
bazille c'est dans cet immeuble qu'une
adolescente de saison a été violée puis
torturé pendant plus de deux ans semir à
une jeune fille d'origine marocaine
était séquestrée par un couple français
elle était condamnée aux tâches
ménagères et a subi des traitements
extrêmement violents notamment des actes
de torture au couteau à plusieurs
reprises c'est finalement les voisins
qui ont donné l'alerté
cette enquête nous a révélé qu'elle
avait subi diverses vis notamment
sexuelles et nous avons vérifié auprès
des experts tous les tout ce que nous
pouvions vérifier en sur les brûlures
écoutons elle parlait et ensuite nous
avons interpellé les deux personnes le
couple mardi dernier en juin dernier la
jeune fille est assez dans un foyer
d'accueil
mais ses tortionnaires n'ont été
interpellé que mardi nous étions en
présence d'un homme qui disait que cet
enfant était sa fille et on ne retire
pas une fille à ses parents ou à son
père puisque les jeunes il indiqué que
c'était une fille naturelle de manière
aussi spontané que l'on va venir
chercher chez vous un objet défectueux
si vous voulez il fallait réunir s
attendre d'éléments pour savoir ce qui
se passait vraiment ce que l'on n'avait
pas du tout réussi à faire lors de la
première phase de l'enquète hier le
parquet de versailles a ouvert une
information judiciaire pour viol
séquestration et violences avec arme sur
mineur
le couple de tortionnaires encourt une
peine de 20 ans de prison
une page sportive du rugby avec demain
le match très attendu france ecosse le
quinze de france tentera de faire
oublier ses récentes déconvenues dans le
tournoi des cinq nations
alexandre kara hervé pozzo l'importance
d'être constant
pour jean-claude skréla le sélectionneur
c'est une règle de vie mais surtout une
règle de rugby aux commandes de l'équipe
de france skréla s'est juré de mettre un
terme à l'irrégularité maladive du
quinze tricolore
et pour être honnête il faut avouer que
depuis trois ans les bleus ont souvent
brillé
c'est peut-être une une qualité une
qualité qui devient un défaut la terre
on est capable de se sublimer
ponctuellement pour certains matches les
bialé
les situer bien les gérer les gagner
capable du meilleur les bleus de france
savent aussi offrir le pire comme en 97
à grenoble une semaine après avoir
remporté le grand chelem
la france s'incline face au modeste
italien comment 99 les bleus archi
favori du tournoi trébuché face aux
gallois
une première défaite au stade de france
en 80 minutes le champion annoncé de
l'hémisphère nord c'est cool les bleus
entrent à nouveau dans l'ère du tout
il s'agit pour nous maintenant de de
relever la tête et à partir de là de
s'inscrire dans une continuité justement
de résultats positifs en vue de la coupe
du monde simplement donc il n'y a il n'y
a pas de fatalité
il n'y a que du travail quel que soit le
résultat face à l écosse le tournoi 99
demeurera un mauvais cru pour les bleus
mais le vrai travail ne commencera
qu'après le tournoi avec la préparation
de la coupe du monde
il reste six mois à l'équipe de france
pour retrouver un moral de conquérant et
catherine ceylac ray dans thé ou café
demain matin recevra thomas castaignède
un bel anniversaire pour la pyramide du
louvre qui fête ses dix ans 21 mètres de
haut 2 100 tonnes d'acier de verre
rien que l'année passée près de 6
millions de visiteurs pour cet emblème
français pierre emmanuel luneau bernard
que nord ce n'est pas déplacé ça
n'enlève rien à la beauté lui reste
parce que c'est translucide
pour moi c'est déplacé ça ne va pas avec
les restes des bâtiments gens
s'habituent et je m'habitue à cause d'un
possible le louvre sous la pyramide
elle a à peine 10 ans et pourtant elle
est aussi célèbre que les grands la tour
eiffel ou notre dame ont du souci à se
faire
la pyramide du louvre est devenu un
monument français incontournable
l'architecte américain ieoh ming pei
choisi par françois mitterrand en 1983
était ce matin au pied de son oeuvre
plutôt fier de lui c'est un très grand
jour pour moi je suis profondément
heureux de voir comme c'est devenu
maintenant un vrai lieu de fête
ce n'est pas très original d'ailleurs
fait lui même n'a pas pu l'éviter
la photographie devant le monument il
faut dire que nos visiteurs ont fait
honneur au nouveau musée du louvre en
disant il a vendu 50 millions de tickets
d'entrée
et pourtant le grand louvre était un
pari risqué quatre cent mille mètres
cubes de faire déplacer un ministère des
finances déménager et surtout ce choix
pharaonique pour le moins d'une pyramide
au beau milieu du palais des rois de
france
prochaine étape de cet immense chantier
la salle abritant la joconde c'est pas
quel projet sera retenu parmi lesquels
cinq projets sur lesquels vous
travaillez en ce moment et fera
évidemment une salle qui j'espère une
ira comme toujours cela était le cas au
louvre le passé et le moderne moderne et
classique la recette a semble-t-il bien
fonctionné le louvre n'est pas prêt de
perdre sa place de premier musée du
monde
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres dans le
confirme yougoslavie le président russe
osz le temps et évoque les risques d'une
guerre européenne voire mondiale si les
états unis poussent en même temps la
russie assure qu'elle ne s'appliquera
pas militairement dans la crise l'aide
humanitaire en albanie en macédoine avec
aujourd'hui sur la sellette le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés son efficacité
est mise en cause par différentes
organisations
alors qu'en france cette solidarité
s'organise des connus pour les réfugiés
et des milliers d'appels pour les
accueillir dans un instant la météo
nathalie rihouet puis le point route de
valérie maurice 20h55 taratata présentée
par nagui avec liane foly super trump
khaled faudel à 0 h 35 le dernier
journal laurence ostolaza je vous
retrouve demain dès 13h merci de votre
attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
autre